we'll never really know what drove them
to have that war all the reasons that
were given we know our laws there were
no weapons of mass destruction there was
no terrorist connection between between
Hussein and terrorism I think in some
ways it was sheer arrogance it was a
sheer belief that if you have power you
have to express it where you can express
it and I think that that came out pretty
clearly we are the most powerful we can
do whatever we want this is the next
thing we're going to do and if Iraq had
worked out there would have been a next
thing probably Iran which they still
might try to get away with so I think
you know there have been everything from
psychoanalyzing bush in his relationship
with his father which surely may have
had something to do with it to Cheney's
you know Cheney obviously just had a
sheer thirst the ravishing Aravis
ravenous thirst for the expression of
power he still does I mean his great
illuminating moment a few weeks ago was
when someone said you know what about
the fact that the American people are so
against the war now and he said so
that's really the expression of power
that means I have so much power I don't
have to listen to even the American
people so I think that's where the war
started
the media the media takes a lot of the
blame the New York Times takes a lot of
the blame as the as the journal of
record as it's called with Judith Miller
takes a lot of the blame basically it
was the media following I mean someone
did a commercial recently or a
documentary showing how the Republican
Party would say something about what was
the justification for the war and then
you'd hear members of the House and
Senate using precisely the same words
and between the government controlling
the House and the Senate at the time and
the media of being so malleable and
gullible and not doing its proper work
there just wasn't enough force in the
opposition
I'll read the pump of relating to what
we were just speaking of relating to the
the frustration of knowing that before
the war started what was going to happen
it's called Cassandra Iraq Cassandra was
the great prophet at Troy who foresaw
what was going to happen that Troy was
going to fool and when she spoke um
people couldn't understand her they
actually thought that she was speaking
like a bird that they heard birdsong and
of course she was right and then at the
end after Troy fools she's carried away
by Agamemnon and ends up die as he does
Cassandra Iraq she's magnificent as we
imagine women must be who foresee and
foretell and are right and disdained
this is the difference between us who
are like her and having been right and
disdained and us as we are because we in
our for seeing's are having been right
or repulsive to ourselves fat and
immobile like toads not toads in the
garden who after all are what they are
but toads and the tail of death in the
desert of sludge in this tale of Lies of
treachery of superfluous dead where
they're ever so many who were right and
disdained with no notion what to do next
if we were true Sears as present as she
as frenzied we'd know what to do next we
Twitter as she did like birds we'd
warble we trill but what would it be
really to Twitter to warble to trill is
it EEE like having a child is it uh uh
like a wound or is it inside like a blow
silent to everyone but yourself yes
inside I remember oh
it's where grief is just about to be
spoken but all at once can't be oh when
you no longer can think of what things
like lies like superfluous dead so many
might mean Oh Cassandra will be abducted
at the end of her tail and died even she
can't predict how stabbed shot blown to
bits her abductor dies too though in a
gush of gore in a net that we know she
foresaw that in a gush of gore in a net
should I reread that place where I own
bubbled a little Cassandra will be
abducted at the end of her tail and died
even she can't predict how stabbed shot
blown to bits her abductor dies too
though in a gush of gore in a net that
we know she foresaw that in a gush of
gore in a net
there's a huge amount of political
writing in our time and there's a huge
meat amount being heard whether that
means anything or not is another
question you don't know there's this
fusion and history between moments when
people can hear just like Cassandra when
people can hear what's being said and
what's urgent and when they can't and
you can't predict you can't know when
the times are that people will hear what
they're supposed to be here and there
should be here
you